[Musique]
à plus de quatre heures d'avion de pékin
les monts tianshan émergent à 6000
mètres d'altitude
nous sommes au think he yang l'extrême
ouest chinois musulmans et turque le
pays des ouigours
à bord uniquement des chinois des hommes
d'affaires à qui pékin réserves les plus
gros contrats
comme eux nous nous rendons à kashgar
kashgar la cité mythique de la route de
la soie une cité aujourd'hui dans l'oeil
du cyclone chinois
le rien à voir avec marco polo marchands
de tapis et caravansérail ont été
balayées par de moderne centres
commerciaux
visiblement les affaires marchent bien
le 21e siècle parle définitivement
chinois dans cette vieille ville
turcophone istanbul a laissé place à
pékin
[Musique]
en général il n'y a que des chinois ici
pas de ouïghours nous on vient du et
chante ici
[Applaudissements]
ça fait 20 ans qu'on vit à kashkal
deux peuples deux mondes qui ne se
mélangent pas dans tout le team kiang
les chinois sont presque aussi nombreux
que les ouigours 8 contre 9 millions et
kashgar ne déroge pas à cette règle les
turcophones perdre un peu plus de
terrain chaque année
pour retrouver l'univers turc nous nous
rendons au grand marché de kashgar un
marché célèbre dans toute l'asie
centrale
ici rien n'a changé depuis des siècles
la chine n'a pas réussi à s'imposer
cherchez bien parmi cette foule vous n'y
verrez pas un chinois tous les dimanches
les bêtes continue de changer de main
selon des méthodes ancestrales pas de
contrat la parole donnée suffit une
parole en ouigours évidemment
[Musique]
les ouigours ne veulent pas vendre leurs
bêtes chinois sont obligés de payer un
autre rigourd pour le faire à leur place
si tu dis là quoi vas-y vas-y fais ton
malin
mais est-ce que tout va bien pour vous
ici
les affaires sont bonnes tout va bien
c'est même mieux qu'avant
nous constatons rapidement qu'on refuse
de nous parler politique encore moins de
critiques et pékin paranoïa ou peur
justifiée nous allons tenter de
comprendre le malaise qui s'est emparé
de ce phare ouest chinois
abdourahmane un agriculteur ouïghours
qui vend des légumes sur le marché
accepte de nous inviter chez lui
il vite à quelques kilomètres de kashgar
dans un petit village de paysans
[Musique]
abdourahmane à 50 ans et quatre filles
la politique de l'enfant unique n'est
pas de rigueur ici et les dérogations
s'obtiennent assez facilement
chez lui le confort est rudimentaire et
le salaire du paysan quelques dizaines
d'euros par mois suffisent difficilement
à nourrir toute la famille
il n'y a pas de chinois et si jamie cade
a dans mon village nous sommes 45
familles que des ouigours
les chinois eux ils vivent de l'autre
côté de la route tout près des champs
qui nous fait l'état chinois
ses voisins chinois abdourahmane les
fréquentes de temps en temps ils
acceptent de nous présenter l'un d'entre
eux
à peine 1 km séparent les deux villages
peu de ouigours entre ici tout
simplement à cause de la barrière de la
langue
qu'est ce que tu fais ici
qu'est ce que tu veux hein quoi je te
comprends pas mais qu'est ce que tu veux
mais qu'est ce qu'il raconte une fourche
dialogue de sourds pour se comprendre
les deux hommes ont besoin de notre
traducteur
le voisin d'abord à manx ou libyens du
sichuan il vit ici depuis une dizaine
d'années avec sa femme et il a laissé
ses deux enfants dans sa province natale
à des milliers de kilomètres d'ici
car
ils sont nombreux à posséder des terres
les travaux des ouigours ne sont pas
difficiles juste des tâches subalternes
et plante un peu mais ils ne savent pas
travailler
juste des choses simples et en plus ils
ne travaillent que cinq heures par jour
par exemple ses murs là ce sont des
ouigours qui les ont fait ça m'a coûté
1500m 150 euros ils ont fait 100 mètres
de mur pour moi c'est tout ce que je
peux leur demander
quelques mètres plus loin un champ de
coton
une quarantaine de femmes s'activent
elles sont ouigours et elles ont toutes
le même employeur un chinois
cette terre appartient aux chinois pour
dix ans
et nous on travaille pour eux mais vous
n'avez plus rien non ce n'est pas notre
terre
auparavant toutes ces terres appartenant
aux ouïghours
aujourd'hui ces femmes sont payés à la
tâche pas cher à peine 5 centimes
d'euros le kilo de coton ramasser elle
n'en dirons pas plus la surveillante
chinoise ici avec le chapeau ne les
quitte pas des yeux
[Musique]
à qui appartiennent ces terres louées
aux chinois qui les distribuent à qui et
pourquoi
pour en savoir plus il faut se rendre à
urumqi la capitale du xinjiang
plus de deux millions d'habitants à 80%
chinois est partout en ville des hôtels
de luxe des chantiers par centaines
[Musique]
or uci siège du binh thuan le bras armé
financier de pékin créée il ya cinquante
ans pour contrôler le team kiang
l'organisme dépend directement des
militaires tout le business de la région
passe par lui
alimentation alcool cosmétiques mais
aussi assurances ou financent les
activités du binh thuan semble sans
limite
soon ping travail pour cet organisme un
peu spécial
dans les années 50 beaucoup de
militaires sont venus d'autres provinces
jusqu'au xinjiang
on leur a demandé de devenir fermier et
de participer à la reconstruction
mon grand père était militaire mais
maintenant mon père et moi ne sommes
plus militaire
des fermiers soldats comme à la pire
époque de la révolution culturelle quand
marc dirigeait la chine
permission exceptionnelle accordée à des
étrangers nous sommes invités à venir
visiter le fleuron du big one
l'un des leaders mondiaux de la tomate
lusine chalky stomato
comment cette usine du bout du monde est
elle devenue la reine du concentré de
tomate
évidemment chinoise li na szczesny l'une
des responsable commercial c'est elle
qui assure la visite guidée et elle est
fière de nous faire le tour du
propriétaire
elle nous fait d'abord rencontré un de
ces fermiers soldats quand on ne manque
de main d'oeuvre on en fait venir par
camion
comme lui tous les paysans qui
travaillent ici sont chinois tous
obéissent au big one hot sinkiang ils
sont en tout 2 millions à dépendre comme
de l'organisme militaro financier
c'est une politique d'incitation la part
du bing tuân
il encourage les fermiers à s'installer
ici
ces tomates d'ultimes kiang finiront
dans les assiettes africaine russe ou
même françaises et italiennes
notre guide nous emmène ensuite dans le
saint des saints de toute division
agricole du binh thuan une pièce qui
fait office non seulement deux salles de
réunion mais aussi de siège électoral du
parti communiste et de maisons des
soldats toute la vie d'un salarié du min
oignies et régis comme le montrent ces
petites étoiles attribuées comme autant
de bons points aux employés qui ne
doivent jamais oublier qu'ils sont avant
tout des militaires
le binh thuân un rôle particulier en
temps normal ces membres sont juste des
paysans
mais dès que la tension monte dans la
région ils redeviennent des soldats sont
le soutien arrière de l'armée populaire
en fait ils servent à dépanner l'armée à
des moments précis
[Musique]
les fermiers sont des soldats oui les
fermiers sont des soldats
gardot rucci fin de matinée d'un jour de
semaine comme les autres des centaines
de migrants chinois attendent d'être
embauchée pour la prochaine récolte du
coton la plupart n'ont même jamais mis
les pieds au sin kiang
on a voyagé jusqu'à orochi pour ramasser
le coton
en marche depuis des décennies la
colonisation chinoise de la province
continue
cette situation les ouigours la
supportent de plus en plus mal ils
s'estiment exclus du miracle économique
de leur propre région
depuis le début de l'année 2008 certains
ont eu recours à la violence
une série d'attentats attribués aux
ouigours ont fait une vingtaine de morts
des attaques qui justifie aux yeux de
pékin de durcir encore un peu plus sa
présence policière et militaire
et pour une fois sans le risque d'être
montrée du doigt par l'occident puisque
l'ombre d'al quaida plane sur ces
attaques
au moins deux attentats ont été
revendiqués par des terroristes ouigours
proche du parti islamique du turkestan
oriental
la petite ville de yama gniards à une
trentaine de kilomètres à l'est de
kashgar pendant un mois elle a été
coupée du monde interdiction d'y
pénétrer
la police traque les islamistes depuis
l'attentât du 12 août ce jour là quatre
fonctionnaires était tué à l'armé
blanche sur les murs une campagne anti
musulmane dont la république populaire
de chine a le secret et qui rappelle à
tous le danger du terrorisme et
l'absolue nécessité de l'écraser
parmi les victimes se trouvaient le
responsable des mosquées du secteur tué
pour avoir collaboré avec les
communistes
son successeur vient d'être nommé et
nous tentons de le rencontrer
on finit par nous indiquer qu'il
travaille à la mairie
vous êtes journaliste non des touristes
à peine entré dans son bureau le piège
se referme sur nous tout va très vite se
compliquer
sur le tableau les imams du district une
faute au manque peut-être celle de
l'imam tué mais nous n'avons pas le
temps de poser la question le secrétaire
du parti communiste de la ville a été
prévenu de notre présence et il n'est
pas content
est-ce qu'ils ont filmée non non non ils
veulent juste rencontrer l'imam
ce n'est pas possible ils doivent avoir
une autorisation spéciale du département
de la sécurité et être accompagnée ici
c'est une zone militaire
eux ils vont partir toi tu vas rester
ici
tu habites urushi tu as de la famille
là-bas un travail
ils vont rentrer dans leur pays mais toi
non
je ne savais pas je suis désolé
alors ne t'amuses pas avec ça tu m'as
compris
ne prend pas ça à la légère ok
on a des endroits visités mais pas ici
quand ce sera ouvert ici ils seront les
bienvenus dit le journaliste mais ce ne
sont pas des journalistes ah oui
d'accord des touristes
notre caméra cachée continue de tourner
mais la menace est claire
et c'est sous bonne escorte que nous
rejoignons notre voiture
partez pas sans vous arrêter au prochain
barrage vous devez me plais compris
sur le chemin du retour la police
prévenue par les autorités de ja magnard
nous interceptera et nous gardera au
commissariat pendant deux heures
pas facile d'enquêter ou ping pong mais
à chauffeur de taxi ouigours va nous
aider ils acceptent de nous emmener sur
les lieux du plus grave des attentats de
cet été celui du 4 août
le matin un groupe de soldats chinois
sans traîner dans la rue ils faisaient
leur jogging dans deux zones bour sont
arrivés au volant d'un camion volé
ils ont foncé sur les soldats par
derrière juste devant la cour de la base
militaire
ensuite ils ont jeté deux grenades qui
ont explosé d'autres soldats sont
arrivés pour secourir les blessés les
deux ouïgours les ont attaqués avec
leurs couteaux et les ont tués
l'un des onze ouïghours avaient encore
des grenades sur lui et il voulait
lancer sur les chinois mais l'une
d'entre elles a explosé trop tôt et
arracher sa main c'est pour cela que les
chinois ont réussi à les capturer
c'est ici qu'a eu lieu l'attentât là
juste là
un carnage en pleine rue seize morts et
16 blessés un choc à la veille des jo
quelques jours plus tard deux
journalistes japonais qui tente de
prendre des photos sont arrêtés frappés
et expulsés par la police
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la situation est plus calme
nous nous rendons sur place dans
l'espoir de rencontrer des témoins
peut-être parmi les employés de l'hôtel
qui fait face
un hôtel de luxe spécialement construit
pour les chinois
pour ne pas éveiller les soupçons nous
prétextant vouloir réserver une chambre
si possible avec vue sur le lieu de
l'attentât
est-ce que c'est sûr dans le quartier il
y a eu des problèmes ici enfin un peu
plus loin
mais rassurez vous c'est un endroit sûr
la sécurité a été renforcée dans tout le
quartier
c'est la consigne officiellement le
calme est revenu mais si les auteurs de
l'attaqué ont été arrêtés rien n'a été
résolu bien au contraire les ouigours
n'ont jamais autant été déterminée
traduisez cette phrase maintenant nous
illustre moi aussi j'en peux plus de ces
injustices
mais j'ai une famille à charge des
enfants
si j'étais célibataire je prendrai plus
de risques j'agirai je m'en ficherais
cas police m'arrête me condamne à la
prison à vie ou même me tue mais j'ai
une famille
vous savez nous les ouïgours on a
beaucoup de haine pour les chinois
fassent preuve de toute cette pression
qu'ils nous font subir en permanence
cette haine est elle justifiée
l'oppression est elle si terrible les
ouigours reproche aux chinois de vouloir
détruire jusqu'à leur culture en tout
cas la vieille ville existe toujours
pékin on a même fait un musée vivant et
comme dans tout musée entrée payante
la caisse est tenu par des ouïghours
mais où va l'argent dans les poches du
gouvernement local contrôlé par les
chinois
depuis les attentats les touristes se
montre bien discret à kashgar et la
vieille ville en ce mois de ramadan
semble comme endormi
l'islam justement un sujet qui reste
tabou ici
encore une fois nous cherchons à en
savoir davantage nous nous approchons de
l'unique école coranique de la ville
nous tournons en caméra cachée et nous
cherchons à rencontrer le directeur de
l'école
bonjour bonjour
ce sont des français il voudrait
discuter avec vous de l'islam sinkiang
vous n'avez rien à faire ici
vous avez une autorisation de l'état
non je vous le répète vous n'avez rien à
faire ici alors partez je ne veux rien
vous dire partez
ok notre passage éclair n'échappe pas
aux policiers dans la voiture son bras
gauche chargée de surveiller les allées
et venues dans l'école coranique
et c'est ainsi partout pour toutes les
mosquées qui sont interdites d'accès aux
moins de 18 ans comme le rappelle ce
panneau en théorie du moins comme nous
l'expliquent le moisi de l'une d'entre
elles la loi il sait comment la
contourner
si des jeunes de moins de 18 ans entre
dans les mosquées l'imam et le mézinais
risque une amende
c'est à nous de leur interdire d'entrée
comment faites vous pour les surveiller
ce que je dis aux contrôleurs c'est
qu'avant la prière je peux facilement
empêcher les jeunes de venir mais une
fois que je prie ça m'est impossible de
surveiller l'entrée car je suis de dos
alors c'est des jeunes viennent et même
si je m'en rends compte je ne vais tout
de même pas stopper ma prière pour
autant
en chine on n'a pas le droit de prier
cinq fois par jour on n'a pas le droit
d'être un bon musulman
malgré les menaces aux abords des
mosquées les fidèles ne cachent pas
leurs convictions religieuses et par
centaines les musulmans attendent avec
impatience la rupture du jeûne du
ramadan
l'appel à la prière se fait sans haut
parleur le régime l'interdît
[Musique]
la prière terminée la vie reprend son
cours presque normalement dans la ville
ouigours
personne ne prête attention à la
télévision chinoise diffusé en pleine
place centrale
comme toujours depuis des siècles les
restaurants de rue s'active une fois la
nuit tombée
les ouigours en oublierait presque que
la présence chinoise
au beau milieu de la nuit nous avons
rendez vous chez un professeur
d'université ouïghours
comme tous les fonctionnaires du pays il
lui est interdit d'être musulman il fait
le ramadan au cachet à dix
après maintes hésitations il accepte de
nous parler face caméra mais le visage
de l'universitaire devra être masquée
dans les écoles le midi on donne à
manger et à boire pour les étudiants et
les enseignants ainsi on vérifie s'ils
suivent le ramadan ou pas
la pression politique s'intensifie en
permanence comme il n'ya pas de liberté
d'expression ici la revendication risque
de devenir de plus en plus forte donc
comme ça s'est passé à kachgar où
ailleurs certaines personnes vont
choisir la violence est ainsi les
chinois vous rend les traités de
terroristes
les ouigours se sentent en danger
ils craignent de disparaître à l'image
des mandchous et des tibétains devenus
minoritaires à l'intérieur de leur
propre région est transformé en
prétextes folklorique
un seul chiffre en 1949 date de la prise
de contrôle du think tank par les
troupes de mao les chinois représentait
6% de la population locale ils sont
aujourd'hui plus de 40%
la province ouigours tentent de résister
à la formidable pression chinoise mais
pour encore combien de temps
m